[Music]
my oh my River babes you have no idea
what you're in for
I'm your host Liana Galera and welcome
to the beginning of the end I mean
welcome to the Sweetwater secrets
preview show for episode 221 chapter 34
judgement night now side now apparently
this episode used to be called chapter
34 the killing of a sacred deer but they
changed it at the last minute I don't
know why they changed the episodes title
but I'm glad they did because that last
one was a little bizarre and a little
spoilery
and judgement night is a much better fit
for this absolutely bonkers episode
since I'm channeling my inner juggy
today that'll make sense later I'll be
bringing you exclusive scoop from Cole
Sprouse about his favorite Jughead
moment of season 2 plus Madeline touch
is setting the record straight about her
biggest Shoni pet peas but first let's
take a look at your hisses and kisses
from episode 2 20:33 shadow of a doubt
first up Luna Apollo dished hisses to
the black hood for being near Sherrill
stay away from my sis kisses to be in
see they're so cute and to the Serpent's
all sticking together in unity there is
strength hard eyes meanwhile Carly Rock
was not seen hard eyes and she unleashed
a mini rant writing okay let's get this
straight here it's perfectly fine for
moose to cheat on midge with Kevin in
season 1 but when moose finds out that
[ __ ] of the same thing this season
with fangs suddenly moose gets angry
major hisses two moose for being a
complete hypocrite not understanding
that you're a horrible person doesn't
make you less of a horrible person
breach girl but I've gotta warn you he's
not the only hypocrite in town you're
gonna want to punch during this week's
episode as for fangs fate
random person yes that's their actual
handle posted Reggie couldn't have shot
fangs because Archie was on top of him
before he was shot which meant he would
have only been able to shoot his leg or
his foot yeah I'll agree that the angles
definitely seemed off during that scene
but at this point I'm not really sure
the laws of physics really apply to
Riverdale it was a physic Turner plan
ass
and Jamie on throughout this gem of a
comment writing hisses to the fact that
we still haven't seen Nana Rose since
she basically saved Shoney's
relationship yes give us all nano rose
all day and speaking of Shoni megan
louise cosplay said um can she stop
calling Joanie Joanie hmm Megan my dear
I'm assuming by your spelling in that
comment that you pronounced Shoni like
Joanie don't get me wrong I love that
we're on the same [ __ ] but Cheryl is the
SH sound so it's shown me not Joanie but
hey you don't have to take my word for
it I'll let Madeline Pech take it from
here and like five months ago when I was
when I was calling that Joni was gonna
happen and we created the ship name
together do you remember that
conversation I think I just clarified
that it's Shoni I'm not Tony
it is not Joni I have been saying show
me Cheryl
Joanie Tony reminds me of and who is
captaining that ship from the beginning
you were little does enough so was she's
like I want to date Cheryl okay all
right from the Shoni Queen herself it's
shown E in our last sweetwater I pitched
my theory that the other black hood in
town could either be Claudius or the
potential identical twin of house I
don't know but Linnea is dropping a cool
new twist with this kind of lengthy
comment so hang in there with me all
right
she says I have a theory that the black
hood actually works for Hermione Marysol
hinted that the season finale might make
you question where she stands my guess
is that it'll somehow involve the black
hood house unusual green eyes during
parts of the episode may also be a hint
that it's not actually how but yet
another twin one theory could be that
the twin would be working for Hermione
but made a deal to save Betty somehow
but instead he had to torture her and
possibly have to figure out who was in
the process possibly a part of the deal
he made with Hermione honestly it would
be the smartest move in the less obvious
choice you just said a mouthful there
sister great job that was a mouthful but
I applaud you meanwhile it appears that
my rewinding sesh of the body bag son
was a little
because dreaming with a 1 instead of an
eye welcome back girl commented land
that would nothing like chick am I crazy
I really thought that the dead body
looks so much like chick I just maybe
just the adrenaline of the moment just
got to me I I'm sorry we're just two
episodes away from the end of season 2
and I'm already getting a little
nostalgic you know it was amazing to
watch jugheads journey go from reluctant
South Side High student to the fierce
serpent prince he is today so when I
caught up with Cole Sprouse
at PaleyFest a few months ago I asked
her to reflect on juggies journey take a
look looking back on this season what
has been your most crazy favorite
Jughead moment my most crazy favorite
Jughead moment I mean Jughead
straight-up cuts his enemies now if I
were to read the abstract from season
one ago this kid cuts people with a
switchblade I would be shocked but he
does he does it well and confidently and
it keeps eye contact the whole time
I contact you're not going to want to
even blink when you see the last five
minutes of judgement night now as we
move into the penultimate episode of
season 2 you can tell from the promo
that this one's going to be amazing but
I need to warn you river babes if you
are some dumb folks looking to just get
murdered this episode has everything
action revenge
kidnapping answers serpents ghosts
ghouls goblins my son the list goes on
and on and now I'm going to tease you
even more because here are three clues
you need to know before tuning into this
next jaw-dropping episode number one
that wasn't a scream that was a battle
cry and you won't believe what this
fiery character does next number two
three of Riverdale's most attractive
residents will team up for a hot and
heroic rescue mission and number three
don't believe everything you hear
it could lead to one phanpy
Britt down the path to their demise are
you shaking in your snakeskin boots yet
well you should be
now once you've watched chapter 34
judgment night grab your tissues you're
gonna need them and come sob with me on
the Sweetwater secret after-show we're
all have exclusive answers from the
surprise Riverdale star about the
episodes most haunting moment but for
now please give this video a like and
hit the comments or chat with me on
Twitter to shout out your predictions
for what's gonna happen and if you can
crack my three clues
see you soon river babes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]